[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MANDEL: Hi, and
welcome to episode
number 178 of the weekly
Google Cloud Platform podcast.
I'm Mark and I'm here
with Mark, as well.
How are you doing, Mark?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I'm Mark.
I'm also Mark.
How are you, Mark?
MARK MANDEL: I'm
very well, Mark.
How are you doing, Mark?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Mark is doing great.
Wait, which Mark is?
So I think I'll call
myself Mirch for now.
I know that our accents
are also very similar.
[LAUGHTER]
MARK MANDEL: Of course.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So we don't
want people to get mixed up.
MARK MANDEL: Yes, yes, yes.
But today we have Chris
Aniszczyk from the Linux
Foundation, CTO of
CNCF and VP of DevRel
at the Linux Foundation
talking to us today
all about the Linux
Foundation, Open Source
Foundations, open source
stuff, all good things.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
It was a great conversation
that we had with him.
You know, I'd heard of
the Linux Foundation.
I think most people
have heard of Linux.
But there's a lot of open
source projects out there.
And it turns out they can
sometimes be hard to manage.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So I think it was
really cool to hear what the
Foundation does, how it helps
people out, and kind of like
what that almost governing body
provides for all these
different communities.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, absolutely.
And then I get to ask you a
super interesting question
where I ask you, how
do I connect Cloud
SQL to my serverless thingos?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Something
very, very interesting.
And we'll have an
answer for you.
But before we get to that--
MARK MANDEL: Cool
things of the week?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
All right, what you got?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
first cool thing of the week,
I'd like to call out
a blog post written
by one of our very
own DAs, Felipe,
who wrote a very, very cool and
interesting little cover of how
do you analyze ride share data?
So we're here in
the Bay Area where
traffic is admittedly quite
a disaster most of the time.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: And
I think a lot of people
are always wondering
how long it'll take.
And it turns out Uber actually
released some public data
sets, including
how long it takes
to get from certain destinations
to other certain destinations.
And then Felipe,
who loves BigQuery--
MARK MANDEL: He does.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
--decided to take all that,
put it together, and show
off a cool little Data Studio
dashboard using the new BQ
business intelligence unit
product.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That basically makes
it super quick to analyze
and do actual BI dashboards.
So the Medium post walks
through kind of how he did it.
It sets it up so you can
take a look at more than just
the Bay Area.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And it calls out
that we have a lot of cool
public data sets for BigQuery.
So I think that
was really awesome.
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
Awesome.
I have one that I
think is lots of fun,
mainly because I like
seeing machine learning
agents do very silly things.
There's a contest going on over
at Unity called the Obstacle
Tower Challenge.
We are a sponsor of the
prizes, which is lovely.
But basically, the
first iteration
is now complete in which
teams are challenged
to build an AI agent that has
to navigate a procedurally
generated obstacle course.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I can't navigate
a procedurally general--
[CRASHING] How is an
AI going to do it?
MARK MANDEL: Through AI.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Oh, good point.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Hadn't
thought about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, pretty much.
So this is really cool.
Yeah, so the first
stage is complete.
Check out the details, which
will be in the blog post.
And soon some teams are
moving on to round two.
They've received more
than 2,000 entries
from several hundred
teams around the world.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Very cool.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's
a good one to watch.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Speaking of BigQuery
before with Felipe's
blog post, well,
there's actually
another cool blog
post that came out a little
while ago that talked
about BigQuery's GIS tools.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
And these are things
that are useful for
calculating distances kind
of similar to the public data
share that Uber had sent out.
In this case, it turns
out that even though we're
talking about positions
on earth most of the time,
you could actually
take the same concepts
and put them into
astronomy terms.
So now we're able to
look at huge public data
sets of astronomy stuff
and then take that
and say, OK, well let's
use the basin coordinates
to figure out where they are,
gather all this big data.
So now we've got all the
power of doing rapid big data
analysis and comparing it
to what could possibly be
the biggest data set there is--
space.
Space.
[ECHOING]
[CREEPY MUSIC]
MARK MANDEL: Super big.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
So I hear.
People tell me.
I haven't quite seen
all of it myself.
MARK MANDEL: I tried
seeing it once.
It took me-- I got bored.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Is
it-- it's not worth it?
MARK MANDEL: There's just
a lot of black stuff.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Mark
review 1 out of 10.
Would not recommend.
MARK MANDEL: So
finally, for me, we
have another blog
post, a GKE Sandbox,
bringing defense in
depth to your pods.
At Cloud Next we
announce the GKE Sandbox
in beta, which is a
new feature of GKE.
So if you feel that you
need increased security
and isolation of
your containers,
this might be a
nice thing for you.
It's based on gVisor, the
open source container sandbox
runtime.
Basically, if you're running
anything that potentially maybe
is like slightly untrusted,
like someone's providing you
user code or you're running
a multi-tenancy environment,
you might want to try this out.
It's pretty cool.
We'll link to it in a blog post.
But basically, with a couple of
extra annotations on your pod
and a new type of thing
inside your node pool,
you're pretty much good to go.
And then you can
just continue running
as you were before with just
that extra layer of security.
It's pretty sweet.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I
think we're seeing
a lot of cool customizations
that you can have now,
because there's one
thing to be said
about Kubernetes
and then actually
having to manage Kubernetes.
But now it's like, how many
little buttons and bells
and whistles can I
start to get on there?
And this is just another
one in the latest line.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
I think that's everything.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, well, one more.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, one more.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Last but not least,
we do you have a
quick announcement
for a great new public data
center that just got launched--
MARK MANDEL: Very true.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: --over in
Japan, I believe in Osaka.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
that brings us to,
what, 20 regions worldwide?
MARK MANDEL: That's a lot.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It's
nice to see, right?
So people can kind
of choose when
they're going to launch their
services where they want it,
make sure they can kind of get
that closest to the user as
possible.
Always a good thing to have.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
And additional regions are
coming soon with Seoul,
Salt Lake City,
and Jakarta coming
in the first half of 2020.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Very, very cool.
And not that far off.
MARK MANDEL: No.
Well, why don't we go
have a chat with Chris
about all the open source
things in the Linux Foundation?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Sounds good.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
OK, so super excited.
We have my dear buddy, Chris
Aniszczyk, here joining us
at Cloud Next.
CTO of CNCF and VP of DevRel
at the Linux Foundation.
How are you doing today, Chris?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Pretty good.
It's nice to be in
this small little house
that we have here for
the podcast booth.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Our listeners can't see it, but
it is an adorable little house.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: It's adorable.
It's comfy.
It's cozy.
It makes me feel at home.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: Does
your house look
like a giant yellow
Plexiglas building?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: I mean, well,
if I moved, it took a while,
it was expensive.
I was like, hey.
But you know, San
Francisco rental prices.
MARK MANDEL: Before
we get too ridiculous,
do you want to tell us a
little bit about who you are
and what you do, like
CNCF, Linux Foundation?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah, sure.
I mean, I basically
have two roles.
You know, I serve
as VP of DevRel
at all of Linux Foundation,
which basically means,
if people aren't familiar
with the Linux Foundation,
it's really not only
about Linux anymore.
We kind of are a family
of foundations, right?
We have things like
the Node.js Foundation,
or I guess it's the
Open JS foundation.
There is CNCF, which
I helped start.
There is the Automotive
Linux Foundation, and so on.
So I help basically run
DevRel for across all
these different
foundations and make
sure those communities
of developers
are very happy in those
respective communities.
But most of my
day job these days
is focused on really taking care
of the CNCF Technical Community
as a CTO, so working with our
independent technical board
to make sure we're
accepting wonderful projects
into the community, and
also making sure in general
our projects and developers are
super happy with the services
that the Foundation provides.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Now, that
makes a lot of sense to me,
except for one part.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You listed
a lot of foundations there
and a lot of different teams.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Let's
start with the highest level.
What is the purpose of
the Linux Foundation?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Cool.
Very simple.
So if you like go pull up
the bylaws and charter,
the Linux Foundation
is basically tasked
to support and sustain
the development of Linux
and open source software.
And that open source
software is very broad.
So initially, Linux Foundation
started out very focused
on Linux, like
Linus and Greg KH,
the stable and
unstable maintainers
are employed as fellows
and go hack on the kernel
and make sure to
take care of it.
But eventually what happened,
as Linux grew and just
in general open
source grew, people
were trying to find ways
to kind of collaborate.
And if you kind of
look at it, there's
a lot of different
foundations out there.
There's Apache, but
their kind of motto
is very much focused
on the individual
and they kind of pretend
companies don't exist.
It's very individual community,
and they're volunteer runs.
So there's no
necessary services.
The Linux Foundation is more
of a professional services
kind of foundation,
where we actually
have people on staff that
help with marketing, DevRel,
technical writing, all the
stuff that generally project
maintainers don't like
to do but are super
useful for building community.
Running events, we're
putting on KubeCon Barcelona
in a month and a half, soon,
and it's almost a 10,000 person
event.
That's a lot to put
on, but actually super
useful to build communities.
So we are kind of a full
service professional staff
organization.
We've grown to
support open source
in all different industries.
People would come to
us and say, you know,
Toyota, hey, we
want to do something
in the automotive industry
to bring open source to cars,
to make things more
efficient and innovative.
We've worked at
the telco industry,
so we have Linux
Foundation networking.
We cleaned up the mess
with the [INAUDIBLE]
and merged those things
into one organization.
So we've kind of
just grown through--
Linux was one of early
open source projects,
and people naturally came to
our organization for help.
MARK MANDEL: So you said--
I mean, you said support.
And then you've also
listed a wide variety
of very interesting things that
you do for open source projects
as a whole.
Is there any limit to that?
Like, how does that get
coord-- like, what happens--
CHRIS ANISZCZYK:
Yeah, so I mean,
think about each kind
of sub-foundation,
it kind of runs
independently, right?
They have their own-- you could
think of it like a business
unit, their own PNL and
potentially own staff.
But the parent entity
is the Linux Foundation.
So they kind of basically
work with the community
to figure out what they need.
I kind of have a saying
that each open source
project is unhappy in
their own unique way.
And you kind of have to work
with them to figure out,
maybe you need
infrastructure help.
A lot of the telco
focused foundations,
they have physical devices, like
routers and other crazy stuff.
And so you kind of need a lab
to kind of help them with.
Others may just
need help with-- we
don't like technical writing.
We kind of suck at it.
Can you help us with that?
So we do kind of a
variety of things
based on each type of project.
But the LF's a fairly
decently large organization.
Like, we also host things like--
people forget letsencrypt.org.
You know, everyone
loves free SSL certs.
We basically helped--
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK:
--bootstrap that
and sustain it, essentially,
as an organization.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So I mean, that's
still a long list of
things that you do.
But it's really interesting
when you mentioned
that groups or open source
groups will come to you
and say, we need
some help doing this.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yep.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
How does that group
OK with working with like, hey,
let's just sign everything over
to this foundation?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah.
So I mean think about
it, businesses inherently
don't trust each other,
right, in many ways, right?
They feel like, oh, you're
going to sue me for something,
or unless there's some type of
agreement or partnership, well,
by putting code and
some level of IP,
whether it's a trademark
in a neutral place
like we did with Kubernetes.
We have this wonderful
conformance program
that everyone works
with and ensures
that they respect the
project and are conformant.
We set these types of things
up for different organizations
for different industries,
verticals, and projects.
So having a neutral entity and
the IP owned in a neutral way
builds trust across
these companies.
And they decide
together what they
want to work on together, like
what part of the industry,
maybe, is commoditized
at some layer,
or some interesting thing they
kind of want to chase and work
on together.
So essentially,
neutrality builds trust,
and to me is a cornerstone
of working together.
MARK MANDEL: So you handle
intercompany politics really
well.
[LAUGHTER]
CHRIS ANISZCZYK:
So I will tell you
the sad thing about this job.
It unfortunately makes
you respect politicians
a little bit more.
And that's painful.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I
mean, it highlights, right?
Like, I'm sure there are and
there have been no shortage of
and probably
currently are plenty
of conflicts between
different people
wanting to go different ways--
MARK MANDEL:
Different incentives.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
--and different people
in the community
who are just like,
I don't know if I want to
be governed by some higher
authority that I didn't choose.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK:
Yeah, or they compete
at the market at some
level and someone's
like, I want to go push this
feature into something that I
may sell.
But at the end of the day,
like, we very much focus
on open source projects
and making sure
they are very healthy,
sustained, and do everything
to make sure they're healthy.
Our members build products
that compete in the market
and go fight it out and
figure out what they do.
And so we just--
our whole goal--
we kind of have the saying of
projects, products, profit.
So we sustain projects.
Our members build products,
sell them, make profits.
And that gets funneled
back into the foundation.
MARK MANDEL: How do
people get involved?
If I've got a little
project where I'm like,
hey, I wrote a little
Go library and I
want to put that in
the Linux Foundation,
I'm assuming that's
not something I can do.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: You
know, there is a process,
if you actually go to the
Linux Foundation org website,
there's propose a
project and there's
kind of like a little forum.
But recently we
announced an initiative
called communitybridge.org.
So maybe you don't need a
full blown crazy foundation,
but you may want to have
support to maybe raise
a little funding for
a meetup or an event,
or you may want
to do internships.
So we kind of even have a,
quote unquote, "summer code
as a service" for
lack of a better--
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: --analogy
that could go all year round.
So we have that
available for people
that are just
individual projects
and may not have, like,
crazy backing or something.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so I know recently
I believe you've
formed a coalition
or whatever you want to call
it for the media association
or something--
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: The
Academy Software Foundation.
MARK MANDEL: That's the
one I'm looking for.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: For
the film industry.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: They don't
want to collaborate either,
but they've decided,
you know what?
Maybe we should
start not reinventing
all these, like, color
tools and other things.
And let's collaborate
on the basis,
because what we're
actually good at
is stories and making
movies, not actually
the software to make those.
MARK MANDEL: How
long did that take?
What was that process like?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Two-plus years.
You know, generally
when these things start,
they don't happen overnight.
Usually one person that
wants to champion open source
in an organization has
realized, like, this is stupid.
We're reinventing the
wheel all over the place.
Comes to us or somehow we
run into them at an event
and we just start
the discussions.
You know, the Linux Foundation
has over 1,000 members
worldwide.
And so we just, like, reach out.
Oh, you know this person here?
And then we kind of maybe host
a little event or a meet-up.
And naturally people come
together and write a mission,
vision, and maybe a
foundation is formed.
Or maybe it isn't.
So sometimes it
doesn't work out.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, I mean,
that's not unique to the media.
There's a lot of industries
that still prefer very private,
kind of closed door,
not open conversations.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: We're actually
seeing other industries
like pharma.
They don't really like to talk
to each other much, either.
And they're starting to dabble,
potentially, in open source.
And so we're just
like into this area
where we're one of the early
pioneers of open source
as an organization,
and we essentially
act as foundation as a service
and bring communities together
that want to collaborate on
some specific piece of software.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
What's the sell there?
I mean, you're not
selling anything,
because ultimately,
you're not paying, right?
But like, how do you go to
and approach these people?
Or do they just come to you?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Just naturally
come to us, generally.
So there's no, like,
proactive reach out.
It's usually the
problems are actually
coming from the businesses
or people that have them.
So we're not actively
going out and saying,
you should do open source.
Open source is great.
MARK MANDEL: What
sort of problems
do you think they're trying
to solve with open source?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Cross
company collaboration.
So generally there's
some piece of the stack
that they may want
to have commoditized,
just like the Academy Software
Foundation, all these color
tools that they've come up
with they're reinventing
on their own, and their
company policies do not
allow them to easily collaborate
with different organizations.
So if you put the
code in a foundation,
there's usually an IP policy
that everyone agrees to,
a fair governance policy
that everyone agrees to
of how maintainers are
elected and removed.
And then all of a
sudden, the companies
could collaborate
together in a fair way.
That's, like, a sports
match or something,
where everyone knows
how the rules of hockey
work and there's a
referee or something.
So let's go at it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Do you also work
in the other way, where
you may go into companies
and educate them
about open source
and, like, how they can work
in that arena in a better way?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: 100%.
Half my job is
probably educating
companies that are
new to open source
or don't understand
how it works.
It's actually-- my personal
vision of open source
is sustained by
convincing companies
that, A, open source is a
good thing that they should
contribute to, either
by hiring maintainers
or contributing to
projects and just being
involved in the communities.
And we tend to live a
little bit in the bubble
sometimes in kind of like
the Silicon Valley area.
But if you go out to automotive
companies or pharma companies,
they haven't heard of
Kubernetes, you know,
bless their heart.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I can't imagine--
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah,
open source is new to them,
and so we do a lot of education.
We have free resources,
guides that we produce.
I co-founded one initiative
called the todogroup.org where
I used to run the open source
office at Twitter where we just
produced a bunch of material
of, like, how to contribute
open source, how
to start a project,
how to work with
others, you know,
what happens when things
go wrong in open source.
And so we just open sourced
all these things available
for companies to
learn from and use.
MARK MANDEL: I know
I've definitely
run into companies where I
know members who would just
be like, I can't even write
feedback on a GitHub project
because, like, legal or PR
is not going to like it.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: You
have to go through the 11
circles of legal and PR--
MARK MANDEL: Every time.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah,
every time, for a patch
or for everything.
Yep.
MARK MANDEL: But I think you do
some legal services, as well?
Is that right?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah, we do.
We have legal staff and
external counsel on trademarks
and just legal
advice in general.
Like, the Linux Foundation, by--
you join the organization,
there's actually
a legal network and
they have, I think,
conferences twice a year where
all these lawyers go into room,
which I want to avoid.
But they talk to each other
and they learn from each other.
That's just kind of
one benefit of being
part of the organization.
And usually a huge
function of what we do
is education of how
open source works.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
that's an interesting point.
People can still be
part of the foundation,
but they don't necessarily
have to open source code.
They may just be
there so that they
can interact with open
source code in a healthy way.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK:
Yeah, absolutely.
I mean, all our projects don't
require any form of membership,
right?
Like, all technical stuff, you
just show up and contribute,
you know.
It's a duocracy, essentially.
Like, if you show
up, maybe you'll
become a maintainer
or something.
The funding there is just
to sustain us, like--
it's not cheap to put on KubeCon
or technical writers and so on.
So that's kind of where the
resources go to sustain that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So that's
a pretty helpful overview
of why the Linux
Foundation is important
and some of the reasons
that a lot of people
might look at some of
the projects there.
But you mentioned that you've
been spending a lot of time
on CNCF.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah, I
was employee one start--
with CNCF and the open
container initiative
at the same time,
which if you remember
the wonderful container
wars of days old.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Are
we settled on that?
Is that good?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: OCI--
we have containers--
we have an image spec.
We have a runtime spec.
The team is actively working
on a distribution spec.
So oh my God, wouldn't it
be amazing if registries
had the same kind
of API out there
and there wasn't any crazy
issues where one didn't support
multi arc support or something?
So they are, like, working
together on those problems.
And they've made
a lot of progress.
Almost every container
runtime supports the OCI image
and runtime spec at some level.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So
I was going to say,
you were, like,
number 1 at CNCF.
Where did that come from?
What was the need?
Why did that come about?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: No, it's
kind of an interesting story.
I spent five years
before joining
the Linux Foundation in
Twitter working on open source
infrastructure.
So we had our containers, Mesos,
before they were really cool.
I quit that job after
five years of startup.
Good times.
Learned a lot.
And then I was--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Living
in the valley, right?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
I was like, I need a
little time off after that.
And then had this
wonderful conversation
with the head of the Linux
Foundation Jim Zelmin,
who called me and
was like, you know,
Google has open
source Kubernetes.
You know, there's
a bunch of folks
that want to build a
standard around containers.
You want to come help this?
You've had a lot of experience
in open source and so on.
It's great.
You know, we're nonprofit.
It's going to be super easy.
Just come do this,
and you know--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It's
basically a vacation.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah,
it's going to be easy.
Oh, not for profit, like,
you get like 30 vacation
days or something.
It's going to be great.
You know, it turned
out to be super--
I don't want to say
painful, but very rewarding,
like, bringing together--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Challenging.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Challenging
is probably the better word.
But bringing together
competitors to, like,
essentially
collaborate and decide
which parts of the stack,
essentially, we actually
want to commoditize or agree
that we should standardize
is a fun experiment.
And it shows kind of the values.
I don't think if we did not do
OCI and help grow Kubernetes
where it is today, it
wouldn't have worked out
without getting that agreement
on container formats and so on.
Otherwise, like, if you
go to a different cloud,
you have to go, like,
rebuild your containers
or use another format.
It would be a nightmare.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Yeah, I mean, I
think that's a
very valuable point
to why these things exist.
Again, going back to why
these foundations are
kind of helping people.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah.
And I think the
other useful thing
is, I do want to say, like,
when Craig McLuckie and Sarah
Novotny and some
of the other folks
that were very early involved
with the foundation is we
made a deliberate decision
not to just call it
the Kubernetes Foundation.
It was going to be the Cloud
Native Computing Foundation
and encompass more than just one
specific project or technology.
It was to come up with a
kind of, here's our mission.
We want to spread Cloud
Native, bring projects together
that are very
useful in the space.
We don't necessarily want to
anoint one technically project
as a winner.
We kind of want to build
some specifications.
And it worked out pretty well.
I think we're a lot more
successful with that mission
than just specifically
saying, we're
just the Kubernetes Foundation.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So you were
employee number one CNCF.
What does Cloud
Native mean to you?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Oh my gosh.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we ask the
hard questions on this podcast.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: No, it's great.
So you know, what's
kind of funny
is when we started the
organization it was like,
Cloud Native is
all about services
that live in containers
that are orchestrated
by some central process.
And that was kind of like
the originally thing that
was baked into the charter.
But recently, we had this
funny debate within the CNCF
technical community of,
maybe we should write down
the definition or update it.
And so it's actually
been updated.
It's on GitHub.
It's actually much
longer than I like.
But essentially, it encompasses
that original definition,
but it includes more
things like service meshes,
concept resiliency, and so on.
So if I had my computer in
front of me, I could read it.
But--
MARK MANDEL: That's OK.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: It is too long.
But it is something
that the community of--
we have hundreds of
members, thousands
of developers that actually
came up, agreed upon, and voted
on it.
It's translated into,
like, Chinese, Japanese,
Korean on GitHub.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Is that going
to continue to grow, though?
I mean, especially as the
ecosystem kind of rapidly
is right now exploding
in every direction,
how is the Foundation going
to be able to kind of oversee
a good chunk of that?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: We're no
longer one person anymore.
There's a staff about--
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That usually helps.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK:
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
There's a staff of
about 30 or so folks
that work directly
on CNCF full time.
We have a lovely booth here.
I don't know if you swung by.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It's great.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah, exactly.
It's very pretty.
We have lots of stickers.
So if you're into, like, you
know Fluentd, containerd.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I have a
few stickers on my laptop.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: [INAUDIBLE].
I saw some podcast stickers
that somehow ended up on the--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Strange.
How did that--
MARK MANDEL: I don't know.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It's weird.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Exactly.
We have a decent
amount of staff now.
So we have about a little
over 30 projects now.
And as we grow as
an organization,
we try to staff
up appropriately.
And part of our work is not
only staffing the Foundation,
but also working with
companies to convince them
that if you're betting your
business on Kubernetes,
you know, maybe you
should try to contribute
some resources to translate the
Kubernetes docs into Japanese
or contribute in your own way.
And a lot of companies
actually need that education
because they're very new
to open source, you know.
It's very surprising if
you're just living in the Bay
and sometimes you go talk to
a bunch of crazy customers
or people that are
new to open source.
There's lots of them.
We're still kind of in
the early days of people
understanding open
source, in my opinion.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, I mean.
It's not-- I mean, it's
not necessarily crazy.
It's just different people at
different levels of the stack.
And that's just
where they're at.
And that makes sense, right?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: So I mean,
that sounds good from a like,
you can join this foundation.
You can get this support.
If you don't like
it, you don't join.
Very simple.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Or you could
still always contribute code.
Like, if you want to
fiscally support it,
you're more than welcome to.
But it's not a
requirement by any means.
So if you're building, like,
Kubernetes conformant type
things, then yeah,
maybe you should
support this
organization cause you're
betting your business on it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Have
you run into any people
who are actually
resisting the Foundation?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: It's more
of an education, like,
so what do you necessarily do?
Or it's like, oh, I have
this Kubernetes distribution.
Oh, there's a
conformance program.
Oh, it's run by CNCF.
I had no idea that this existed.
So it's more of just educating
people on kind of what we do.
We produce these kind of
amazing annual reports.
I don't know if
you've seen them yet,
but if you go to the CNCF
website, go down there
and find the latest annual
report, it kind of shows
the amount of events we put
on, the amount of diversity
scholarships that we've done
in the organization, the amount
of contributions we've
done as an organization.
So we kind of just
publish all that
and try to educate
people out there kind
of what the organization
does and how they
could kind of get involved.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Sounds like there's a
lot of stuff that happens
at the organizational level.
If I'm just a lone developer
typing away in my cube,
what have you done
for me lately?
Like, what does the CNCF and
the Linux Foundation kind of
do at the individual layer?
Or is it just more like,
I'm helping you build stuff
and that's cool?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK:
It's a combination.
Everything on an
individual level,
it's like, we've
given out, I think,
last year 300-plus
diversity scholarships
if you're an individual
coming from wherever
and, like, hey, I want to
attend my first KubeCon.
So we've done a lot of that.
Like, it's hard.
Like, from a Linux
Foundation perspective,
it's like, use letsencrypt.org,
get free SSL certs.
MARK MANDEL: That's true.
That's very true.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Exactly.
With the community bridge
platform that we launched,
now we offer summer code as a
service any time for projects.
And so you can go
have an internship
anytime of the year, instead
of just a specific time.
So I think as a
politician we have
multiple constituents right?
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
I like that.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK:
We have members.
We have individuals, developers.
And so we try to
provide services
for all different
types of constituents
because they have
different cares and needs.
Back to my saying, like,
each open source project
is unhappy in their
own unique way.
And we do our best
to kind of work
with different types
of people, companies,
and so on, to
address your needs.
MARK MANDEL: What
interesting trends
are you seeing at the
moment across open source?
Are you seeing anything
that's changing
the landscape over time?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: I don't want
to talk about the whole open
source licensing gate, you know,
stuff going on with companies
coming up with kind
of bespoke anti-type--
I'll say cloud licenses.
I think it's just a long topic.
But the thing that I see the
most is new industries that you
would not think
would have anything
to do with open source, you
know-- the automotive industry,
the pharma industry--
cities even
are starting to want
to collaborate and even
share data amongst each other.
So a lot of trend of
like, new industries
that you typically would
not expect to do anything
with open source are
starting to realize
that we would like to
collaborate, potentially,
with each other, and we kind of
want a fair and neutral place
to do that.
So we're getting approached a
lot by these new industries,
even the gaming industry, giving
back to our original meeting
at GDC.
MARK MANDEL: What has been the
particularly challenging thing
that you've been working on?
Because I know-- I'm
guessing there's a lot,
I mean, working with
varying interests
and various incentives.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: I mean, I
think it's sometimes difficult.
You know, as an organization, we
are still somewhat of a small,
non-for-profit.
So we are kind of limited
in resources in some ways
when we kind of
start new things.
So recently, I was working
with Facebook on a project,
a technology called GraphQL.
Solves a very
interesting problem.
And there was a large
community of folks
out there that wanted to see
GraphQL in a neutral place.
And so it was a
year-plus project
to kind of make that
happen, you know, convince
the right parties,
work with lawyers,
and eventually that was kind
of done as like a side project.
And now that the Foundation
is finally kind of formed,
it could be properly staffed.
So we kind of have this
weird bootstrapping problem
where you know, someone will
come to us with an idea,
and you know, let's just
work on this on my side
and figure out what,
you know, eventually--
I'll make it work and then we'll
get it staffed appropriately.
So it's kind of a-- we have a
bit of a resource constraint
type problem when it
comes to new projects,
because we are kind of
fairly small compared
to these wonderful billion
dollar companies that
are all around me.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, exactly.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
What's on your wishlist?
I mean, what are you
really hoping to see soon?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Like I
said, my focus is CNCF.
Like, keeping our
projects, you know, happy,
avoiding conflict
as much as possible,
making sure that
we continue to grow
the diversity in our community.
Infrastructure as a
space tends to just not
be as diverse as other parts
of software, in my opinion.
So we do our best
to ensure that we
add tons of diversity
scholarships
for a lot of our
KubeCon related events.
And I mean, last year I think
we threw over $300,000 last year
in diversity scholarships, which
is the most of any open source
foundation.
And to continue to grow that
to make sure our community is
inclusive and diverse, I
think, is super important
and something that
I'm personally
passionate about at the
Linux Foundation and CNCF.
MARK MANDEL: So if I'm either
a company or an individual
and I want to get involved,
either with the Linux
Foundation or CNCF,
where should they go?
What should they do?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK:
I mean, generally
most people get involved
at the project level.
It's like, oh, I use GraphQL.
I'm going to go
contribute to that.
Or I use Spinnaker, I'm
going to go find that.
And then most of the times,
a lot of these projects
are just project
first, and they just
happen to live in the
Foundation that kind of holds
the trademark or IP or whatever.
So just go to the projects that
you normally contribute to.
You may be surprised
that they're
part of the Linux Foundation
and you have no specific idea.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
There's probably
people who work on
this stuff and have
no idea what the Foundation
does or anything of that nature.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah.
We do our best to
try to message,
but our whole
philosophy is to let
the projects do
what they're good at
and try to stay out of the way.
We don't, like, force crazy
governance or anything.
We're just basically kind
of like referees and neutral
holders of IP to ensure
people behave, essentially.
It's kind of-- imagine
a sports match.
It wouldn't be fun if you
were playing in a game
and one team had an advantage
over another or something
and the referee wasn't
really doing their job.
And so we try to make
sure the rules are fair
and these organizations
are supported.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: If I'm
a company, or even, like,
a group of people
who are like, oh,
I think we have a
great project that
would be a great fit somewhere,
is there like a [INAUDIBLE]
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: You can
go to linuxfoundation.org.
You go to projects.
I think there's
like, Post a Project.
It's a link.
Go check it out there.
You know, last year we hosted
events that probably nearly
had 35,000 or 40,000 people.
Go to Open Source
Summit, you know,
we're doing one in
August in San Diego.
Go to KubeCon.
We host a lot of different
events out there.
So that's one way to get
involved with the community.
But go to the website.
We have a lot of information.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Before we finish up,
is there anything
we haven't covered,
something you
want to make sure that
the listeners know about
before we get done?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: No.
I mean, a lot of
times, the simple thing
is people get confused at,
like-- the Linux Foundation,
obviously Linux is
a big part of it.
But we do a lot more than that.
You know, a lot of
people don't realize
we support letsencrypt.org.
We fix the Node, io, js things--
now that's actually Open JS.
So now the Node.js foundation
and the JSF slash jQuery folks
all merge into one happy--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Oh, nice.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: --entity.
So just that we do a lot more
than I think people realize.
And so check out our
website and kind of go
to our projects page,
and you'll be surprised
what's actually on there.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Have
you considered the tagline
"More than just Linux"?
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: I
lost that war of,
like, maybe we should
rename the foundation.
And then--
MARK MANDEL: Or could we just
get some stickers, I think?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Linux Foundation--
more than just Linux.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Yeah, exactly.
Yeah.
No, every time you
get a free SSL cert,
you know, send a little love
to the Linux Foundation.
We helped make that happen.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
thank you very much for that.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you so much.
CHRIS ANISZCZYK: Thanks
for the conversation.
This has been fun.
MARK MANDEL: Cheers.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Yeah, so
that was a great conversation
with Chris.
Obviously, thanks so much,
Chris, for coming in.
Super, super cool to hear.
I didn't know much about
all these open source
foundations and kind of why they
were so important in the world.
And obviously, with all
these different people
kind of working
together, I can see
why they might need a
little bit of support
from the higher layer.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
Definitely love that.
Well, let's get stuck into
the question of the week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
What I want to know is,
if I've got Cloud SQL,
how do I connect that to
my serverless thingos?
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, I--
MARK MANDEL: That's the
technical term, by the way.
Thingos.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: The thingos.
Yeah.
See, here at Google, we have
lots of thingos for you to use.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
[CHIMING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well, if
you're not using thingos,
but instead you're using
something like, oh,
I don't know, the recently
announced Cloud Run--
pretty good offering, I
think, for most people--
it turns out it's
becoming a lot easier
to connect in these things.
So traditionally, you might
have something like, you know,
opening up your SQL to public
IP address, which is a fantastic
idea and everyone should do it.
[BUZZER]
Do not.
MARK MANDEL: Do not do that.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: The
sarcasm did not come across.
Yeah, clearly there's a lot
of security implications
with opening up a database
to the outside world.
[CHIMING]
So oftentimes, people
don't want to do that.
So in the case of Cloud
Run or in the case
of serverless
offerings, it can be
kind of tricky to
understand, well,
you can't just whitelist a
few IP users or something
like that.
It's not as easy to connect.
Well, thankfully,
there's a cool blog post
where Cloud Run talks about
some recent additions they've
made since the kind of the
next open beta for everybody
to try out.
And one of them is just a
very really quick command line
argument you push in called
Add Cloud SQL instances.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Couldn't be much easier.
So if you're running Cloud
Run on the kind of just
hosted version, which
has all the serverless,
then you can kind of just
add in that command line.
You pass in your Cloud SQL
instance and you're good to go.
If you're running Cloud
Run on Kubernetes,
so you have a little
bit more structure
and that's kind of the
Knative aspect of it,
then it's actually pretty
easy to follow a different set
of instructions,
but you're adding
a proxy in front of Cloud SQL.
So you take that proxy, you
connect to that instead,
and you still kind of maintain
your private cloud SQL.
So all the details
are in the blog post.
It's actually two
lines, I think,
if you want add it to Cloud Run.
So super, super easy.
And I think that that will open
up a lot more access for people
to run databases along
with their serverless apps.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
Very, very cool.
All right, well, before
we wrap up today, Mark,
what are you up to?
What are you doing?
What cool things are you doing?
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
Well, I'm working
on a lot of video
projects, so hoping
to come out and view some
customers on the east coast
soon.
And just in general,
you know, I try
to live my life without
moving as much as possible.
MARK MANDEL: As
much as possible.
No arm waving.
No leg shaking.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So far, so good.
I'm hoping to record the
podcast from my desk next time.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, nice.
That would be not good for--
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Could
I record it from my bed?
That's really the question.
MARK MANDEL:
Actually, that's good.
You'd have, like, really good
audio quality because it's
probably quite absorbent.
[CHIMING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: I hadn't
actually thought about that.
But now you're actually-- let
me put this document together.
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
Yeah, anyway, cool.
All right.
What am I up to?
Looks like I'll be speaking
at Next Tokyo in July.
So if you're in the region,
please come by, say hello.
August, I will be
at the Open Source
in Gaming Day, which is right
before the Open Source North
America Summit.
I may or may not be speaking,
I have a [INAUDIBLE],,
but I'm on committee,
so who knows.
I don't know.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Can you vote
for yourself in the committee?
MARK MANDEL: I cannot
vote for myself, no.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: You know what?
That makes a lot of sense.
MARK MANDEL: It does
make a lot of sense.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Unless there
was some kind of foundation
to tell people how to run these.
Oh, wait.
We just talked about that.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, exactly.
And that's exactly
the Foundation
that is running the Open
Source North America Summit.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Good tie-in.
Good tie-in.
I like it.
MARK MANDEL: Thank you.
Excellent.
All right, fantastic.
Well, I think that
wraps everything up.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: Well,
Mark, good to chat with you.
MARK MANDEL: You too.
Thank you for joining me on
this episode of the podcast.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We'll
see you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]